みなさんこんにちは
田治米社長と申します
今宵はどう過ごしでしょうか
皆さんお歳暮の準備はできましたか
私は日頃お世話になっている人に高級マスクメロンをプレゼントしようと思います
メロンというものはとても
福田ものなので
1れやすいですなので初めは果物が傷つかないように
馬込で9なものを加工してあげようと思っています
とても優しいですね
初めは日頃感謝している人たちへの感謝の気持ちでとても笑顔で孫もをつけています
持った
とても楽しそうでいいですね始め
ぞと遊ぶがついていきます笑顔がとても良いですねえええ
少し
顔が険しくなりましたねー
日頃の感謝の気持ちが顔に表れていますね
ああああああああ
あああはぁ
ああああああ
かあさんの気持ちを忘れてはダメよ
ああ
あ
ちょっと怖い方法やばいもうやばいもうやばいをもうやばいもうもう形がやばい形が
じゃないカタチがやら本当は初めはスイカをが良かったのですが季節的にベロンしか
なかったのでメロンになりました
コツは詩歌でしたかったんですねー
大ヤバイ気がする形がいびつになってきましたね
これではちょっともなった人も喜ぶでしょう
お歳暮の準備が整ってきたメロンが自分で立てなくなったことに気づいた初めはメロン
を助けようと思います
います
pou dou dou
持っていた
お歳暮はメロンで